I'm ZT Troy we know each other a little
bit but maybe we could get to know each
other a little bit of course let's do it
[Music]
we talk on a very like hey how are you
how are ya yeah like an outfit yeah like
your outfit I see you but we never
really talk further no okay so we're
gonna pick up topics and then just kind
of like get real what is your gender
identify female I am male for me there's
a little bit of a difference between
gender and gender expression I would say
my nothing like gender is feminine I was
born
anatomically scientifically doctors were
like that's a girl
but as I grew up I was like that doesn't
really work for me I feel like I'm a
more masculine person like ice like a
system elwood like I know I think I
would classify that as well but I'm just
like I'm so uneducated yeah I guess I've
never questioned it either to be honest
with you so what's the worst thing about
being your gender for me personally the
hardest thing is like figuring out when
and where to have my male privilege how
to use it for other people
I do sometimes have a problem with how
women are perceived to be like alright
you're about 25 when you having kids
when you gettin married
I've cost them like minute trash like
that is like and like even as a man I'm
like yes I have very trash tendencies
and like and so like it's like learning
to unlearn sure when are you gonna be
blah blah blah blah that time line is
like yeah I think I think one of the
worst things about it is just feeling
like you're constantly being sexualized
you can't really walk alone at night I
mean like obviously you can but it's
like I've I have not met another like
female identifying person that has felt
comfortable or has not thought about
like oh well it's getting dark now so
if I'm gonna go for like a run after
work I guess I would can't yeah that
sucks
I mean oh no it's not but I mean but in
a way I feel like it is every guy's
responsibility to check their friends
and to like yeah be like dude you can't
do that where do you buy your clothes
swaggy Jax Oh a secret for the innit no
I'm growing up I was always kind of like
a tomboy and like a group of the twin
brother so I would always kind of like I
would wear like boys clothes I just go
straight into the men's department and I
remember the first time that I was like
yeah I can get like all my shirts
they're all my hats I get to buy my
shoes in the little boys department some
places have like plus-size and men's and
I'll go there just to look for street
style because a lot of places that have
plus-size womens don't think that we
want to look streets yeah I hear that
that we always want to be in like flowy
dresses which is what I want buying
pants is really hard
yeah because like they're just like not
built for my body my pants journey is a
hot I'll go shopping maybe once a year
oh yeah so we're was having a sale I do
keep it very simple that I'm not a very
fashionable guy I believe you are lying
I swear you are 100 percent of
fashionable guy it's true listen yeah
but in terms of like where I shot most
of the time it's like it is like in the
guy section and then I also do drag
shame like obviously that is like
exclusively because I feel like when I
do drag it is like hard into the femme
space because like that is like kind the
essence of drag a lot of times have you
ever had to defend your gender when I
was younger like I was real like out
there I'll just just express myself in
different ways got a lot of persons like
I had a blond hair but it was like short
like a little fur like a like cut size
fro I had a tongue ring I a snake bite
as yo so like I know people they they
never said this to me because people
know me to be like in my city like I was
an athlete I was like a great athlete
who me
that so it was like we know this kid is
like super masculine like when he's out
there doing he's dominate so it's like
but it's like yeah I do look like I
don't know I've had to defend like my
manhood innocence of like because I'm
gay people sometimes I challenge you
yeah you know like because I'm more of
like you know I'm a nice person or
whatever so every night people would
challenge that but I would see that as
like a challenge to my manhood and so
when I was younger I would get into
fights a lot because I would just like
snap like that how did you like what was
your process to get to a safer space
where you felt like you know I'm alright
um I guess just with age I started
realizing I I don't need to worry about
what other people are thinking
I've had people like stopped me from
going into women's bathrooms because
they thought I was a dude yeah which I
don't really care I think that I had a
harder time when I looked more
traditionally feminine and presented
feminine to people I had a harder time
defending my sexuality to people you
know how people talk about you know
these women will come out with like
these sexual traumas right and people
just be so quick to be like she's lying
I've noticed that if I look masculine
presenting that for the most part I get
a lot more kind of space and respect of
like I see your thing it's not for me
yeah let's just be cool
whatever I identify as a genderqueer
person a non-binary person so I'm like
that to me means that I'm so aware that
I have a lot of experiences have had
that a feminine person has had and I
also have a lot of the same different
different experiences and like
privileges and a masculine person s so
it's like I'm always dancing yeah yeah
so I don't feel that she or her or even
he and him is the right pronoun for me
so ask people refer to me as they yo cuz
that to me is two experiences there's a
bunch of it in here yeah
[Music]
you